it's case
bring in the jury I don't think so
what is it
the first way this is
I can't hear you later is it gone no not
now
I don't know either why you bring that
up to me before I brought the jury back
in idiot defense witnesses in the
courtroom well you should know and if
there are defense witnesses you bring
them around will swear them and we will
invoke the rule they'll be excluded from
the courtroom so if you have witnessed
defense witnesses and if you don't know
when they remain in the courtroom we're
not little testify now to the ladies to
you ladies and gentlemen I've been
trying to get to you all morning
we attempted to accommodate your needs
to make you comfortable and I hope we've
done so any complaints suggestions we
need to do to change it for tonight
very well now how do I advise you
yesterday I instructed you rather that
you were not to discuss this case you
were not to view any television newscast
in regarding this case you were not to
read any newspaper regarding this case
they have all 17 of you followed my
instructions do I take it that you are
now with an open mind read receive the
evidence of this case I will read this
instruction to you if you would like to
do so you may take notes during the
course of this trial on the other hand
you are not required to take notes if
you prefer not to do so each of you
should make your own decision about this
if you decide to take notes be careful
not to get so involved in note-taking
that you become distracted from the
ongoing proceedings notes are only
memory aid and a jurist notes may be
used only as an aid to refresh that
particular duros memory and assist that
juror in recalling the actual testimony
each of you must rely on your own
independent recollection of the
proceedings whether you take notes or
not each of you must form and express
your own opinion as to the facts of this
case an individual euros notes may be
used by that year or only and may not be
shown to or shared with other jurors you
will notice that we do have an official
court reporter making a record of the
trial however we will not have type
written transcripts of this record
available for your use in reaching a
decision in this case that's the
instruction that I give you at this time
now when we finish the evidence of this
case I'm going to instruct you on the
law and I will give you an additional
instruction at that time regarding the
notes that you have taken now
the 17 of you if you would like to have
a pad and a pencil to take notes raise
your hands and the clerk will furnish
you want if you would like to Leslie
I have reserved the front rows to their
to my right for the families of the
victims and if there's members of the
family otherwise in the courtroom you're
welcome to move forward and also to my
left I've reserved seats for the
relatives of mr. Killian so if their
relatives somewhere else in the
courtroom you'd like to move forward you
may do so to the news media I reserve
seats in the courtroom for you however
we have a number of empty seats in the
courtroom and if you're somewhere else
in the rear and you'd like to move
forward you may do so or call your first
witness
spending now you sit there about
teenagers with that microphone and I
speak very clearly tell us your name
please my name is Rita L bender formerly
Rita Schwerner I live in Seattle
Washington what you did we were I do I'm
an attorney mr. Forester please
I was married to Michael Schwerner we
were married in June of 1962 Oh
when we got married I was 20 he was 22
he had just graduated from college and I
was still in college
I went to the University of the city of
New York and he had gone to Cornell is
that was Bible yes what is y'all Nicky
No Mickey was killed in 1964 - no we
didn't 24
mr. bender 1 you recall your attention
back for the year 1964 you need been
very back to you yes sir
and you admitted to study in Mississippi
yes we came to Mississippi in January of
1964 in Meridian oh I'm sorry
in New York City oh when you came
Mississippi what were you raised we came
to Mississippi to work in the civil
rights movement we were going to work at
establishing a community center in
Meridian which we did and it was a place
where young people could come there was
a ping-pong table and people would come
and play ping-pong and and and talk and
it was a safe place for them to be it
was we got donations of thousands of
books and Mickey and J James Chaney
built bookshelves for the books and we
did reading hours for children the idea
was to have a library with books that
weren't available in the black library
at the time and to help children with
reading it was really in a way a problem
or the the reading classes and the
children's story our really was in a way
a precursor to what became a headstart
program for for preschool children
around the country I don't mean that
that was directly because of the two of
us but it was it was a model that I
think was was used successfully we were
working on voter registration there were
almost no very few african-american
voters in the state of Mississippi at
the time well we lived in a variety of
places sometimes we lived with
african-american families that was
usually short-lived because when word
got out that they were putting us up
they experienced threats and so we had
to leave for a period of perhaps two or
three months we lived in a house that
was rented by an african-american man in
Meridian so that we could use it and we
were able to live there until the owner
of the house received threats and we had
to leave
we then ultimately lived in a in the
upstairs apartment of a house that was
owned by an african-american woman who
was a minister and I'm sorry I don't
remember her name anymore but she really
didn't want us to have that apartment
because it was in such terrible shape
that she said she hated the idea of
having people live there but we really
needed a place to live
and so she agreed we could stay there
there wasn't running water for washing
up and so every morning we went to
Jung's hotel which was the hotel owned
by mr. Jung and african-american in
Meridian and he had said that we could
go there so stay ok well we went every
morning and we showered but we went in
the back door so that there was no
trouble created for the hotel about
allowing whites to use the facilities I
lived in Mississippi I left the state
for about a week sometime in early to
mid May other than that I lived in
Mississippi yes he did sir your primary
base of operations please that didn't
have a Parisian
yes sir I get the feeling from some of
your answers that maybe some of the work
that you doing here was popular tell me
about that little bit there were
constant threats there were calls there
was a telephone at the community center
and there would be calls really on a
daily basis and a lot of them were
either calls in which people use vile
language to me if I answered the phone
or who or call saying that my husband
was dead or I better watch out because
he was going to be killed at one point
when we had the house we were living in
for a few months
we had a telephone in that house and we
would receive telephone calls all hours
of the night with the same kinds of
terrible things being said or else so
just a series of hang-up calls miss
bender while you were here living free
yes did you also reach out
other areas of the community yes
actually
Jay and Mickey did more of the work
outside of Meridian than I did most of
most of my work was at the community
center in Meridian yes sir
you mentioned the night Jay that James
Chaney he had been doing some work
involving civil rights issues before we
got to mirror it in and we met him
shortly after we arrived and he became a
friend and someone whom we worked with
among other local people too he lived in
Meridian miss bender while you were here
how do you try out what we did we used a
station wagon which had been earlier
used by a man named George Raymond in
Canton Mississippi and the license
number of that car had been circulated
among
law enforcement people and others around
the state we started using that car
around March of 1964 and it was the car
we used until the time of the murders in
your work you also come to know Andrew
good
you know I met him very briefly a few
days before his murder when Mickey and
JE and I and a number of other people
who had been involved in voter
registration and other civil civil
rights work here in the state went to
Oxford Ohio for a training program for
summer volunteers who were coming down
to Mississippi and Andy Andrew Goodman
was one of those volunteers and I met
him there miss bender won't call your
attention now
and on May 19th or specifically right
around the border back when I asked you
if you admit you were in Mississippi yes
sir I was familiar with the church here
I am familiar with the mad scientist yes
he and JE both went to the church that
day and spoke at the church they had
been talking for a period of time with
members of the church the church members
were deciding whether or not they would
make the church available for a school
that summer somewhat similar to the the
kind of program we were doing a Meridian
and for voter registration for training
of people who wanted to try to register
to vote in Neshoba County that Memorial
Day the church and so you
follow the demon maybe late
yes sir around the 13th or the 14th of
the month of June we went up to Oxford
as I mentioned with je and a number of
other people from Mississippi also went
up at that time in fact I think we drove
up there with one or two other people
while you were away from Mississippi did
you wanna do something that happened at
the Mount Zion sir yes we learned that
several of the church members two or
three of them fairly elderly had been
badly beaten and the church was burned
that night well the event happened on
the 16th and we learned about it about
two days later about what did you admit
you do in reaction to that
we talked about it we were both
extremely upset about the beatings and
the burning of the church we were very
worried about the church members both
the people who had been beaten and the
risk to any of the other people and I
know JD was very upset too and they
decided that they needed to go back to
Mississippi and miss bender you're lying
you bought treasure sorry I'm sorry it's
it's a little bit emotional I'm sorry
they decided to go back to Mississippi
and go to the Mount Zion Church and meet
with the church members he felt some
sense of responsibility because he had
spoken better than her party he felt a
terrible sense of responsibility about
what had happened to the church members
it was
well this is the spouse of the deceased
and she was with him I think from her
observations of him and his statement
said he made she could form an opinion
as to whether or not he was distressed
not she objection overruled he was
extremely distressed yes I think he and
Jay both felt that they had a
responsibility to the people who had put
themselves at risk and that was why they
they decided they had to go back and see
those people you don't you don't abandon
people who you've put at risk what you
did well originally they went when we
were first talking about it the original
thought was that I would go back with
them and I was asked to stay in Oxford
Ohio to to continue helping with the
training and so the plan was that I
would stay in Ohio for another week and
then I would get a ride back to Meridian
with other people who were driving down
with the
around 3:00 or 4:00 in the morning of
June 20th um Mickey got up he got
dressed he kissed me goodbye and he left
in the blue station wagon this was three
or four or five more yes sir and that
really did saddened
I believe so sir is that last time solid
well that's the very last time I saw
I think he called me briefly Saturday
evening to say that they had arrived in
Meridian and that they were planning to
go up to Philadelphia the next day did
you hear them again after they no sir
how is it did you learn that the anger
during the night of June 21st or the
early or early Monday morning the 22nd I
was awakened by knocking on the door of
the room I was saying we were staying in
dormitories at the at the college in
Ohio and asked to come on down to the
office and there was a phone call for me
and I learned that Nicky and je and Andy
had never returned to Meridian from
their trip to Philadelphia he learned
that
you go back
of course this concern there had been
attempts made all that late afternoon
and evening of the 21st to try and find
out what had happened to them
calls to the jails calls to the
hospitals
nobody acknowledged having seen them and
that continued through the night and
into the next day yes I stayed in Ohio
for a couple of days trying to be in
touch with with anyone I could think of
to try to find out what had happened to
them and then decided that I couldn't
stay there I had to come back to
Mississippi and then there was concern
about my coming back by myself
because I had made it very clear I
intended to come to Philadelphia and it
was decided that it was too dangerous
for me and for him for me to travel was
one of the african-american workers and
so it was decided that Bob Zellner who
was a white civil rights worker from
Alabama originally would travel with me
and so we were driven from the college
to the airport in Cincinnati to get a
flight home we were supposed to fly we
couldn't get a flight all the way
through to Meridian
that day and so we were to fly to
Jackson and then on to Meridian the next
morning about how much later after 24th
we became of
well I'll tell you I don't remember the
date but I can tell you I remember
exactly when it was it was the day that
the burned station wagon was found in
the Bogue Chitto area I was at the
airport in Cincinnati and Bob Zellner
and I bumped into fannie lou hamer
who had also been at the college for a
few days and was unknown to us until we
bumped into her at the airport was
traveling back to Mississippi on another
flight and we were standing and talking
when we were we heard that they that the
car had been had been burned whoa
I think it really hit me for the first
time that they were dead that there was
really no realistic possibility that
they were still alive and Fannie Lou and
I mrs. Hamer both started to cry and she
led me over to a bench and she just
wrapped her arms around me and the two
of us had our faces together and both of
us had our tears were mingling with each
other and he cried yes and we stopped in
in Atlanta that night and stayed
overnight with some friends of Bob
sellers and I have a recollection of
sitting at the dinner table with them
that night and they were having a
conversation and I was just sitting
there and
I had this very strange feeling and I
described it the other day when I was
trying to talk about it is what I think
I'm people talk about as being
disassociated I realized I was sitting
there and they were there was this
discussion going on around me and people
were engaging in the normal conduct of
picking up a glass of water and drinking
it or eating their food or talking to
each other and I was there and I wasn't
there and I and I was thinking this is
just very strange
the next day we flew into Meridian and
we stayed a long there were a number of
other people staying there also at
Youngs hotel and some of the black
ministers in Meridian organized
themselves to guard the hotel yes I saw
mrs. Cheney J ease mother in Meridian
and then I Bob and I came up to
Philadelphia I think the day after we
got to Mary
I suppose that you were making an effort
that what happened that's exactly what
what we were doing I stayed in
Mississippi for I think about I'm not
sure exactly ten days or two weeks the
day I think the day after we went to
Philadelphia Bob and I read in the
newspaper that Paul Johnson the governor
of the state was going to be holding a
meeting and a reception with George
Wallace who was then the governor of
Mississippi and in Jackson and so we
decided to go to Jackson and talk to
governor Johnson and they were standing
the two governors were standing outside
on the step so from I think it was the
Statehouse building I think it was the
Statehouse building and there were a lot
of mississippi state patrolman lining
the steps but there were also a lot of
people walking up the steps and greeting
the governor's and shaking hands with
them and talking to them and there were
a lot of reporters around and so we
walked up the steps and I reached out
well just before we got to the top of
the steps I heard a reporter asked
governor Johnson what about these
missing men and governor Johnson turned
to George Wallace and chuckled and said
starik for bed that's that's absolutely
hearsay to Duncan so asked a question to
mr. bender Helen where do you do athlete
I went back to New York for a few days I
saw my family for a few days I saw
Mickey's family I then went to
Washington DC while August over the 1964
in huge that maybe in two other bodies
had been finally resurfaced oh yes sir
I think I was called by Nikki's brother
who had heard it first and called me
that it was terrible yes
photograph please mail and ask you to be
kind of dead laughs this is a photograph
of Mickey Schwerner it was taken in
about April of 1964 in Meridian yes yes
sir miss but lay there and that place
and they'd be received
Yanis all places to have a certain place
for Dre I love you
salsa grammar
more shimmering functions McIntyre I'm
one of the attorneys that representative
injury killing yes attack is a few
questions I like to directly at this
time I've been sitting over there for
some forty five minutes and mission
through your experiences here in
Mississippi and your living conditions
in the transportation and your interest
in civil rights sugar I understand that
after you came back to Mississippi on I
think it's a third time are you were
looking for your perfection and now that
you've got the message that he's
disappeared
yes sir ah the Federal Bureau of
Investigation following you need any
knowledge of it I have no knowledge of
whether I was found to be a Federal
Bureau of Investigation ever yes sir
they did yes sir and how long after the
incident that you found how long after
your knowledge that
disappearances they're talking within
those for several days I can't tell you
exactly when and you don't know that
they've all I have no such information
now we have heard all your living
conditions in the wealth of your servant
acute tragic thing but you know mr.
every way killing no I don't your men to
talk with you the first time I saw him
in person was in this courtroom a few
days ago so far as I can recall
you having a personal knowledge about
the facts of this case concerning the
irregular killings and bombers and the
digging of your husband
well I've read sovereignty no vision
Americans now her no you have no
personal knowledge whatsoever in this
case I have a lot of personal knowledge
in this case up is involved in the case
I don't have any knowledge one way or
the other well could you tell me then
why the state mississippi calls you to
testify
sustained she'd have no way of doing
that but you have no personal knowledge
of mystery killings involved I think I
answered your question
thank you waiter excuse redirect mr.
Cornish would read the testimony
while no
erm sore spot problem
and we have made copies
sorry you have a copy for me
when you say that the next witness that
we are going to call in the case is a
while Alton well unit may be true but
mr. Moran's absolutely correct you've
not shown for a predicate for the
introduction of the transcript the that
the witnesses aren't available
well you should have called her rather
than this to read this deposition
because depth is it this transcript is
inadmissible until you show the
unavailability of the witness connected
up this way you can but certain this
witness is not proper at this time you
must first show the proper predicate
that this mister would Miller is an
unavailable witness now miss benders in
the courtroom now Mr docken the rule has
been invoked and if you intend to call
her again she should not be permitted to
remain in the corner farewell
are you miss teller you were not sworn
this morning did you come around and we
raise your right hand and be swarmed
this lady just right there you solemnly
swear or affirm that's evidence you're
about to give the court in this case
prematurely the truth the whole truth
and nothing but the truth so help you
God would you come around how see miss
Melville pull up closer to my colleagues
well of stage names the recluse me now
Malheur matter where do you live I'm
Artemus ap are you married yes sir your
husband been married yeah the matter
what
Wow this manner deceased whether this
motor insane me tell you what happened
he had cancer
hello Mary Lebanese is your she having
children yes sir
we had three all day nearly malar Ronnie
sue Miller and Carlton Wallace Miller
June is he named after me yes Oh is he
here yes sir yes sir in the back
what does he do he's waiting married in
place apparently what about mr. Wallace
Miller what did he do we died he was
were married in place Department how
long did he serve this breeding place
for 20-some odd years
did he retire
now did he have any military service yes
he was in National Guard
so do you know the defendant in this
case yes sir you recall when you first
met the defendant in this case I don't
remember what mr. killing married me and
Wallace and I don't recall knowing him
before then he proposed the same I said
very much in his house house there
Wallace new defense I was understanding
the team was raised up with him
and whoa au revoir Wallace really came
in the shop Kari so around a little rock
Michelle Chen you can little rock before
Canada neat happening well how how what
was relationship between Wallace Miller
in the defense
well like I didn't know him - emeritus
and my stand they were was raised up
together and went skill gathering and
some kind of related did they ever have
any any problems or disputes with you
Nasr wallet everybody all over NASA you
recall the defendant come to you how
memory yes sir
wait how many times I recalled about
three times three times you were told
about Lynette win that war now I can't
remember that I know he came twice and I
remember sitting in the kitchen talking
and then it was later on for he come
back you how about what year that would
have been
now I sure can't
did you hear about any martyrs of hurt
here so they'll kill three civil rights
work yes I heard back in late as a
matter that I must take up with the
attorneys in chambers would you meet me
in chambers excuse me for a few moments
mr. Oyama legacy
better development because the court to
delete for the progress of this trial
some period of time I'm all let you be
retired to the jury room I hope I trust
their refreshments in that jury room for
the jury and I will bring you back in
when we're ready to continue with kicks
past the jurors
miss Bella your witness in this case
you've all your testimony disheartened
in very brief yeah it that testimony
that you've already given close the door
that testimony you've given is subject
to being cross-examined so i'm not going
i'm all that you leave the witness chair
but you'll be instructed not to discuss
what you testify to or to have a
conversation with attorneys in this case
or to you brought back and forth code
courts call to be in recess for some
little time i'll make an announcement to
you later caution recess
to the courtroom public this
announcement to you as you know I would
expect that mr. Killian is in the
hospital this morning
mr. McIntyre approached the bench and
advised that he was having some
difficulty requesting permission to mr.
Killian to leave the courtroom which I
granted he was then my information that
he was in need of oxygen oxygen was
provided to him and then it was then the
opinion that the emergency medical group
should be so much which that was done
the emergency people was of the opinion
that he should be transported to the
hospital
for there to be examined by some
physician we had a conversation with
that physician so nurse who advised that
he was being examined and treated and
that his he would be submitted then to
the services of another doctor
we you know as you know we recessed and
returned but now we've just had a
telephone conversation with his treating
an examining physician who tells us that
he has not completed all of the tests
that he has he needs to complete before
he can form an opinion as to win and
none of what circumstances mr. Killian
can be released the his expectation his
prognosis is that he can be released
first thing tomorrow morning if so we
can continue with the trial of this case
the law in Mississippi is that if a
person who is awaiting trial and
voluntarily is absence you can try that
person in his absence if he has
knowledge that the case is to be tried
the law is different whenever the crime
when the case is in progress if he
should then volunteer leave then you can
continue with a case but in the case of
illness that is a not a voluntary
absence so I have no discretion at this
time but to recess this case oh and I'll
recess it until 8:30 tomorrow morning
the doctor has stated that he will first
thing tomorrow morning the first patient
that he will see will be mr. Killian and
he then will be in contact and in touch
with the court to advise whether or not
he has been released and if so we can
continue the case
Oh
with that I think that's the explanation
I'll make to you is why we're resetting
for this afternoon with your bring in
the jury
don't know why it is but it's always the
judges a difficult job to explain to
jurors so as to why our cases does not
continue
I've always recognized that jurors are
suspect of the courts that the court is
not moving as fast as it should and
they're having conversation with some
matters unrelated to the case and the
case is being dragged out but in this
instance I want you to know that we've
been dealing with this case
oh the entire time that we've been out
of your presence because of us some
unexpected developments that I have no
control over now I'm required under
circumstances to recess this case until
8:30 tomorrow morning so that's the bad
news numb we'll give you some good news
while we were in recess and out of your
presence you know I advised you that
this year was questioned and we was
going to have court throughout the
weekend and in recognition that Sunday
is Father's Day I've had a meeting here
with the attorneys of the state and the
defendant and through their
understanding it has been agreed that if
we can continue with this case tomorrow
and Saturday morning we'll recess at 12
o'clock Saturday and you all will then
be recessed until Monday morning with
and permitted to go home meaning that
you'll not be here Saturday night or
Sunday night and course that's
conditioned upon you agreeing to follow
my instructions which would be to not
discuss this case with anyone else and
watch newscast and I strongly suspect
that all 17 of you will be kindly and
agree to that
the court will main here in session this
afternoon there are some motions that I
will hear and that arrangement has been
made it would kind of dispose of those
things so that that would not delay the
trial before you anymore so that it has
already so with that announcement I'm
going to let you be recessed back to the
jury room to then be escorted under
arrangement back to the motel hopefully
we can start the case again tomorrow
morn well let you pass through
you
I will meet with the attorneys again on
the matter that we were discussing and
you and far as the courtroom proceeding
is concerned we're recessed until 8:30
to normal